every once in a while we like to do an
official state of the podcast it's like
the president does state of the union we
just check in see that we're keeping
this thing up to quality standards and
that everybody's uh desires are being
met david conan me okay
so what's involved i forget what we do
here
i mean i have no idea
what the state of the podcast is well
the state of the past my desires are not
being met why because you don't know
what what are your desires how can we
better meet your desires well that's
very nice of you um i'd like you guys to
be
a little more complimentary of me sort
of like wow conan um i'm still
starstruck
can't you muster that man
you went you went to contempt almost
immediately when we first started
working together
a couple of years ago and uh i don't
know you know what i mean
yeah let's try and you know what you
know i'd bat it away you know i'd say oh
don't be silly um don't be ridiculous
because i'm a humble man but you guys
always start from a place and you too
david i think you've been around me too
long and you forget when you got off
that bus okay where are you from here we
go you're
illinois you got off that bus with your
cardboard suitcase and your undersized
seersucker suit and that little hat and
you saw those big skyscrapers and went
garsh
uh and and came and worked for me you
were excited and then suddenly
you quickly became the same cynical
uh prick that matt gourley is wow with
that intro i can't believe he doesn't
gush praise
all right david let's you and me give
him some praise let's see how naturally
it comes
you're really funny yes i am next
um um people think you're hilarious yes
they do next you got a good working
knowledge of history yes i do
thank you next
see i said i was gonna bat them away and
i'm not
i'm just accepting them and asking more
a voracious need
machine oh
yeah are we done was that enough i think
that covers it yeah you guys acted like
you were
you were saying those words with your
last breath of air that's how it came
across well but david what's it like
when you go back home to is it
carlinville carlinville yeah when you go
back to carlinville and um you go to the
general store and everyone's sitting
around swapping stories
they must say like what's that conan
o'brien like don't they people do ask
about you a lot yeah yeah and what kinds
of stuff do you say that you're really
funny oh come on what do you really say
no i do say that i got i genuinely did
get very lucky working for you because
you are just very easygoing and very
nice right when i moved here i just
heard horror stories of working for
different celebrities right and and i
don't really fit the cliche now i do
sometimes
um act outrageously but it's usually for
comedic effect yeah like one story i
always tell was
it was you had ordered a amazon package
and it didn't show up right so he called
me down and wanted me to go look around
for it five minutes go by sona calls
says conan found the amazon package come
back down in that five minutes you had
taken the time to carve a hole in just a
random box just to flip me off
oh that's right thank you
i i cut i cut a hole in the box and i
said i did find it i found the amazon
package and you were like oh i'm really
glad you found it went yeah and look
what's inside and i opened the box and
gave you the finger i have a picture of
it on my phone and i thought and sona
was howling and i was howling now
i love that this is your story of what a
good guy
but i'm never going to all the trouble
of we sent you
you sent me looking because i went
because it got dropped off at the warner
brothers mail room so i go over talk to
someone at the mail room and then come
back and you were waiting in your office
for me for who knows
oh i remembered
you know we had a show to do
and uh probably a big name guest if i
know our show and uh there was a lot
going on and i was like nope nope i
would routinely tell people the show can
wait i've got to figure out a way to saw
a hole in this box get my hand into it
get the new assistant to sona to come up
here who's from carlinville illinois say
i found the box get you to open it and
then have uh me give you the finger yep
now that that's
man that's a true sociopath at work i
think oh by the way matt uh i found a uh
amazon box for you oh really should i
head right over you should head over
here as quickly as possible okay